wednesday was the last time the u.s
president joe biden was seen publicly
returning to the white house from an
event in massachusetts he appeared in
good health good afternoon everybody but
on thursday the white house confirmed
biden had contracted covid 19. president
biden is currently experiencing mild
symptoms mostly a runny nose and fatigue
with an occasional dry cough hey folks
guess you heard biden's positive case
was discovered during routine white
house coveted testing once detected his
travel schedule was halted and he was
put in isolation still biden released a
photo of him working at his desk in the
white house residents and also a video
to reassure the american public i'm
doing well i'm getting a lot of work
done going to continue to get it done
and
in the meantime thanks for your concern
and keep the faith it's going to be okay
biden is double vaxxed and twice boosted
most recently on march 30 so despite his
advanced age of 79 years biden is
experiencing only mild symptoms
his risk of serious illness
is dramatically lower
he's also getting treated
with a very powerful antiviral
and that further reduces his risk of
serious illness that anti-viral is
pax-lovid and while it's not clear which
strain of covid the president has
contracted thousands of americans have
been hit by an uptick in the omicron
sub-variant ba5 responsible for a wave
of recent covet cases in the united
states paxlovid if taken early is one of
the top treatments
those closest to the president are so
far testing negative dr jill biden the
first lady reassured americans she was
in good health and had no intention of
halting her public schedule
vice president kamala harris has also
tested negative
biden isn't the first u.s president to
contract covid in october of 2020 donald
trump also got the disease eventually
requiring three nights of hospital care
for now the white house staff has been
reduced to essential employees only
while the president recovers but given
his mild case
there are no plans to transfer his
executive powers
to his vice president
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house